joining us here on the red carpet for
the premiere of bullet train it's classy
the fight scenes are incredible the
humor is great and it starts the man who
is next to me right now and a whole
bunch of other people who are fantastic
one of them is very loud right now i
mean i feel like i should say namaste
he's working on his mindfulness
not going so well yeah not for an
assassin i mean it's a real conflict of
interest isn't it
no interesting combination i think i
mean was it the humor that drew you to
this they're fighting themselves
absolutely i mean i read this like in
that in the middle of lockdown before we
even had a vaccine and it just made me
laugh and i thought yeah this is what i
want to see i mean
the director is your former stunt dog
yeah
that's right we met on fight club in 98.
he was my stunt double he trained me for
the fights and we went on to work till
about 04 on a bunch of movies
and then he left me for greener pastures
and then here we are full circle but
he's the boss this time in a way having
that background did he know sort of how
far he could push you i mean
did he get you hurt listen no we're all
game and he's super sweet none the sun
guys are always they're overly
protective of us you know what i mean
overly but this one he designed these
fights with
you know with humor like like
jackie chan esque you know if i could if
i could even compare us to that to the
great i mean the main challenge as well
you're stuck with a bullet train so you
have very confined spaces as well but
that
adds something else yeah yeah again
uh
that was all up to their choreography
it's fantastic we've been boring people
in this country with two things politics
the weather also your skirt of the
berlin premiere i mean would you
advocate other men following your leave
just a skirt i'm going to say we didn't
know about the breeze the breeze is very
nice
very very nice i will leave you with
that thought thank you so much brad pitt
it's a very good film we can't say too
much about it at the moment because
reviews are under embargo but i do think
this is going to be the film that
everyone will be wanting to watch this
summer okay katie thanks very much
indeed brad pitt on the newshour what
more can you want well i suppose maybe a
quick look at the film
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you domo horigato
[Music]
you sure you want to talk this out not
particularly
okay
[Music]